later this year the final ever episode
of Attack on Titan is gonna come out and
in this video I'm going to be doing a
live reaction slash breakdown to the
trailer as I'm recording this video the
trailer is about to come out in two
minutes so I literally have no idea what
to expect I don't even know how long
it's going to be it could be one minute
it could be two minutes or longer
generally don't know but um I have big
expectations because the last episode we
got part three that was just that was
Cinema you know so I'm expecting more
Cinema especially because this is
generally the last thing that we're ever
getting from this series at least maybe
in the future they might do uh more
spin-offs and stuff like that like the
before the fall manga maybe maybe
they'll do that but for now the main
series of Attack on Titan this is it
we're not going to be seeing Aaron again
after this okay it's about to start okay
so it starts off with Armin
wait was that it the trailer was like
the trailer was like uh 15 seconds if
that
I can't even justify that that was
really short it was too short let me
have a re-watch of the trailer just so I
can give like a quick breakdown of what
happened even though not much happened
to be honest so the trailer begins with
Armin and he's basically talking about
how when he was younger he used to race
with Aaron and Mikasa towards that tree
on the hill and towards the end of the
trailer he basically says that he began
to wonder if maybe this is what he was
born to do for moments like this when
he's having fun with his friends and the
reason this is significant is because
Zeke's whole philosophy is that aldians
basically shouldn't be born because
whenever they're born they feel nothing
but pain and suffering and so it would
just be better if they never entered the
world in the first place so that's
Zeke's whole philosophy Armin is a bit
different in that he in this trailer you
can see like he's saying that no even
though our lives are suffering and even
though we're being persecuted and all
this stuff there are Still Moments where
you can find happiness joy excitement
and so it's those moments that are worth
living for I guess that's what arm is
trying to say everything he says in this
trailer is basically a Counterpoint to
Zeke's philosophy following that we then
get a quick shot of Falco's Titan flying
overhead which looks really nice and I
guess the highlight of the trailer which
comes immediately after Falco is there's
this moment where we see a bunch of
ancient Titans so if you are a fan of my
channel you've probably seen that I've
done a ton of videos about ancient
Titans I just I love this kind of thing
just seeing the Titans from the past and
in this scene there are a bunch of them
because of uh well spoilery Reasons I'm
not going to spoil the reason why but
you can see it here there are a ton of
them I think the one in the background
there is uh an armored Titan it looks
like yeah this one is definitely an
armored Titan uh the one on the right is
a female Titan the one down here that
looks like a Minotaur Beast Titan so
that's pretty cool
um I can't really tell what the one on
the left here is though that could be a
draw just based on the Clause there it
could be the draw Titan and we see Jean
holding up Rhino after that we then get
this moment of Mika with the wings
behind her I guess you could say that's
the best shot in the trailer because it
does look pretty epic just her having
the wings and I guess there are layers
to this because you know obviously mixer
is a scout and they have the Wings of
Freedom and in his final episode you
know no spoilers You could argue that
Mikasa achieves her Freedom so this shot
does have layers to it there is a
meaning for the reason why she has the
wings behind her and also it just looks
really cool which is a good enough
reason to do anything so yeah that looks
looks really good in the final moments
of the trailer we then get Bertolt
crying out of one eye which is the thing
that he always does um when Armin
originally got the Colossal Titan we saw
it again but it's all just with one tier
down his eye
um so yeah berto's making a comeback in
one way or another then the very very
final shot of the trailer is a tree
which obviously has a lot of symbolism
in this series and it's mikas's voice
saying I'll see you again Aaron so what
is the significance of that I mean it
sounds like a goodbye
um I guess it's hard to do a video like
this without talking about spoilers but
I'm not going to go into spoilers all
I'm going to say is that this trailer
was uh very short it's not what I was
expecting but does it look good yeah it
looks great I mean from what we saw it
looks fantastic to be honest
um it's just that it was yeah like I
said not as much content as we were
expecting I'm hoping that before the
final episode comes out in the fall of
this year I'm hoping that we do get a
longer one maybe like two minutes long
that would have been nice you know a
good two minutes if this is all we got I
would be disappointed with that I would
be disappointed
um I'm the kind of person who just likes
to see as much content before the actual
thing comes out as possible I know there
are people out there who don't like
watching trailers even like for movies
and stuff like some people just avoid
trailers completely I'm the opposite
like if I like something I will watch
that trailer 100 times so yeah I'm
hoping we get a longer one at some point
down the road
Also earlier today I put up a theory
video about what would have happened if
Aaron's mother survived so if you're a
fan of Attack on Titan in general then
just sub to the channel for more videos
like that and until the next one peace
out